An invasion is here Rhodey and we
can't even tell who the Invaders are
Fury why haven't you called any of your
special friends this war is one I have to fight
alone
this world is burning and it is
this is personal
you're the most wanted man
on the planet
my momma always said I was special
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Marvel just dropped a brand new Secret Invasion trailer
there's a bunch of Avengers references so we'll
break it all down and I'll explain what's
happening with the Avengers right now because
some of them are still alive and we'll get the new
Avengers by Captain America 4. the whole idea is
that during Captain America 4 they're going to
preview what that new Avengers team is going to
look like by the time we get to Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty but they'll be adding members by the time
they get to Kang Dynasty if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course I'll do episode videos when
it starts in the next month they start the new
footage with Nick Fury the real Nick Fury coming
to talk to Rhodey to reveal that there is a secret
Invasion happening there's a group of Skrulls
impersonating world leaders they need to stop them
and the interesting thing here is that it doesn't
seem like Roadie wants to believe him immediately
part of that might just be his skepticism like
we haven't seen you in a while Nick Fury like
he knows the whole thing about the Talos version
of Nick Fury standing in for him while he was on
his spear space station so he thinks that Nick
Fury has turned into a Howard Hughes sort of
hermit type of person like are you just being
crazy are you being paranoid about this is it
really happening and if it wasn't clear by the
events of secret Invasion Roadie has basically
taken Thunderbolt Ross's former job and become
the secretary of state he's meant to be like
the right-hand man to the current U.S president
we know that Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to be
the U.S president by Captain America four but I
believe by the events of secret Invasion he hasn't
yet become the president and it has something
to do with the events of secret Invasion like
once everybody finds out what the Skrulls are
really doing they destabilize things so much
the Thunderbolt Ross takes advantage of that chaos
and rides that wave of popularity that he gets and
trying to get rid of the Skrulls into office but
there is a rumor that Roadie will wind up being a
Skrull on this or a version of roadie and a lot of
you would ask what happened to Rody after Avengers
end game what about all that character development
we saw him during Falcon and Winter Soldier so
there was a real version of roadie at some point
but I think they're going to explain what happened
to Rody when we get to the armor War series like
the whole idea the Iron Man armor War series is
that it'll spin out of secret Invasion and the
whole idea the people have gotten a whole hold of
Iron Man's technology and part of the reason for
that will be how things get destabilized because
of what the Skrulls are doing infiltrating
all these different world governments some
of the footages from previous trailers but one of
the interesting pieces of new footage is Amelia
Clark's character telling Nick Fury that it was
his fault the secret invasion is happening like
it's your fault that all these Skrulls are trying
to take over and what she's actually talking about
is that back in the 90s when they had the original
Skrull event with Captain Marvel and the cree
he agreed to find them a new place to live like
this group of Skrulls that have been held captive
Emilia Clarke is playing talos's daughter she's
in the Captain Marvel movie She's this little
girl she's just older now these younger Skrulls
have evolved new powers too that'll play into the
whole Avengers of it all I'll talk about that in
a second but since the 90s Nick Fury asked them
to lay low like please just keep yourselves quiet
don't let the world know that you exist and I will
find a new place to live but he hasn't made good
on that mostly because of the events of Avengers
Infinity War Avengers endgame everything that
happened with Thanos and the Avengers along those
years he's been a little busy and since Avengers
end game they explained that he's been hiding out
on his space station because he's just been so
broken like he's so weak compared to what he was
like in the original Avengers movie he's like he
used to be this person in a really big position of
power pushing people around the board like chess
pieces and what they're doing is that even though
they're doing things out of order they're trying
to follow the comic book progression of these big
crossover events so secret Invasion everybody
remembers from the comics it was a big Avengers
X-Men crossover event the entire Marvel line like
all the biggest characters you can imagine who is
a Skrull who do you trust what ended up happening
is in the Marvel Comics version of Civil War they
adapted that Loosely for the Captain America
Civil War movie it destabilized the planet so much
that's when princess faraki of the Skrulls decided
to pull off their comic book version of secret
Invasion just because the Earth was so weak and
ripe for takeover the way they're adapting that
progression in the MCU is that it was Avengers end
game like the events of Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game destabilized the planet so much
that it just left it ripe for takeover from this
evil group of Skrulls graphic here is meant to be
the leader of this evil faction of Skrulls from
talos's good group of Skrulls that have just
gotten tired of waiting for Nick Fury to find
them a place to live so they're like okay fine
we'll take the Earth for ourselves then and in
scenes like this where you see Amelia Clarke's
character looking at all these bodies it seems
like these are the important world leaders that
the Skrulls have started to impersonate they're
still alive they're just being held in stasis so
when Emilia Clarke is telling Nick Fury this is
your fault technically it's his fault but there's
a lot of other things that were happening at the
same time like he didn't have control over what
was happening with Thanos in Avengers end game
and when they asked Nick Fury why can't you call
on your special friends to help you deal with this
like The Avengers are super powerful they could
kill all the Skrulls pretty easily there are
a couple reasons for that one of the reasons is
because of the secret Invasion comic book reason
because these Skrulls these younger ones that the
younger generation have evolved to mimic powers
like you can see them using different types of
powers that talos's Older Skrulls can't do part
of what Nick Fury is worried about is that they
could also impersonate the other Avengers pretty
easily when Nick Fury says he has to deal with
this alone part of the reason is he's afraid that
they could just mimic the other Avengers like they
did in the comic book secret Invasion the other
main reason is that a lot of the Avengers have
died and he hasn't put together that new Avengers
team yet some of them are still alive though
so I'll explain what all the Avengers are doing
because some of them are sidelined dealing with
other bigger problems in different parts of the
Galaxy or different parts of the planet in some
of them like the new characters he doesn't know
yet Iron Man died during Avengers end game and as
far as we've seen Nick Fury hasn't let on knowing
anything about him backing up his Consciousness
is an artificial intelligence like Jarvis or
Friday so Iron Man can't help during the events
of secret Invasion Thor is still in a different
part of the universe with Gore's daughter helping
the other lesser races doing what a God should be
doing helping his subjects and other lesser races
that was Gore's whole thing his reason for killing
Gods is because he thought that the gods didn't
care about lesser Mortals we just saw Hulk during
the She-Hulk series he's actually busy right now
dealing with his son's skaar that he just learned
about from sakaar trying to get to know him and
teach him about Earth while also protecting him
from people like Valen Thunderbolt Ross that
want to capture him and use him as a weapon like
they've been trying to do to the Bruce Banner Hulk
himself all these years I believe part of that
plot will culminate in Captain America 4 because
we know they're going to turn Thunderbolt Ross
into Red Hulk so there's a lot of Hulk related
stuff Hulk related characters in Captain America
four like the leader characters coming back
he's going to be one of the main villains in
that we know that Spider-Man is swinging around
New York City and even though Doctor Strange's
spell erased all knowledge of Peter Parker all
the Avengers characters remember Spider-Man
they just don't remember that he's Peter Parker
but the thing about Nick Fury and Spider-Man is
that he actually never really met Spider-Man that
was talos's version of Nick Fury that dealt with
Spider-Man and it sounds like Nick Fury doesn't
want to have anything to do with them right now
that's why he had Talos do all that stuff during
Spider-Man far from home like you deal with the
kid I don't want to talk to him Old Man Captain
America Steve Rogers is basically off the board
for him I believe he's really on Nick Fury's
spear space station living in retirement and
that's the payoff to the reference during Falcon
and Winter Soldier where like there's this Theory
running around on Earth that everybody thinks
that Captain America is retired in a secret moon
base some people they think that he's in the
secret base on the moons like you didn't like
fly them to the moon no there is a moon base
in the comics that belongs to the Watcher maybe
they'll pay that off eventually too but I think
the theory is a little bit wrong and it's actually
him on the spear space station we'll probably get
some confirmation about what's going on with him
during Captain America 4. Sam Wilson's Captain
America new Captain America is busy dealing with
the serpent society which we'll see play out
during Captain America 4 New World Order and
right now even though white vision is super
powerful he basically screwed off at the end
of one division to hide and process the memories
that he regained access to he's meant to be the
original vision from the infinity Saga who just
regained access to all of his memories Nick Fury
at least thinks that Scarlet Witch Is Dead even
though she's technically not dead Natasha Black
Widow died though Hawkeye permanently retired
so he's kind of off the board in Captain Marvel
during the events of the series is increased
Skrull space we won't actually see her till the
events of the Marvels movie and that'll take
place after secret Invasion like what happens
during secret Invasion will lead into the Marvel's
movie even though Sherry's running around is the
New Black Panther Nick Fury doesn't know her and
she's busy rebuilding the nation of wakanda and
her family now that she knows about t'challa's
son baby t'challa and even though they made it
seem like shangshi was joining The Avengers
in his post-credits scene like welcome to the
team and there are a couple Avengers there Nick
Fury wasn't around for that and it sounds like
Wong Hulk and Captain Marvel were operating on
their own together like doing their own thing
when they started investigating the 10 rings of
power in the special signal inside them and even
though Doctor Strange fought with the Avengers
he doesn't consider himself an Avenger and even
if he did right now he's busy in another dimension
like in the dark dimension with clea dealing with
the incursions so that's the main reason why the
Avengers aren't dealing with these Skrulls also
like I said Nick Fury worried that they would
just impersonate The Avengers and make things
way worse part of the whole idea though is that
secret Invasion like once everybody learns about
the Skrulls people like Thunderbolt Ross and Val
they'll use that paranoia to their own advantage
and gain positions of power and it's meant to lead
into a dark rain era of Marvel is 5 like secret
invasion of the comics led to dark Reign like that
happened right after Norman Osborne got a lot of
that storyline but in the MCU I think they're
giving a lot of that to Thunderbolt Ross and Val
Kingpin is also kind of doing his own version
that too becoming mayor of New York City by
the events of Daredevil born again but the echo
episodes will happen before that like they just
announced that all the echo episodes all six
of them will drop simultaneously in November
Daredevil and Kingpin are really big characters
during that so we'll find out what they're doing
right now and I believe by the end of that like as
we head into the beginning of Daredevil born again
which will happen right after that's where Kingpin
becomes mayor of New York City but the whole idea
the whole vibe with dark rain in Marvel Phase 5
is villains taking positions of power in how to
the heroes like how do the Avengers characters
deal with that there'll be a bunch more secret
Invasion trailers in the next couple of weeks of
course I'll do more videos as we get more footage
but leave all your theories in the comments
below and if you have any special requests
for videos just write them in the comments as
well everyone click here for my breakdown of the
new Captain America 4 footage in brand new scenes
and click here for my new Deadpool 3 teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!